good morning the leave nation my name is
Lily MA and my one word is extraordinary
I believe that every single human being
is capable of extraordinary things so to
help you on your journey today's message
is have a champions mind set over to you
Conor McGregor
I mean you're enjoying great riches and
success now but can you put yourself in
the mindset of the guy who was waiting
in line with other people always I'm you
remember what that guy was the case are
you daydreaming of this was that even
possible every second of every day I was
daydreaming but of course I can go back
and think there you know and that's why
I lived there in my environment I always
be there you know I show up on work
every single day like I'm not in the
position on me
like I'm not me so that's the mindset I
haven't it's it's working
in my opinion having a champions mindset
is having the balance between not being
complacent with your success and being
grateful for your success so I think
about myself every single morning I wake
up with the intention that today is
gonna be my hardest-working day yet if I
have succeeded in something I'm gonna
push through and set higher goals for
myself set my standards even higher and
continue to work harder every single day
towards my goal how can I be a better
coach how can I be a better speaker how
can I bring more value to everyone that
comes into my life but on the other side
I am very grateful to have all the
opportunities that are given to me I am
grateful to be standing here speaking in
front of this camera to all of you I'm
grateful to be able to be a coach where
I could help others so knowing the
balance between the two has really
helped me with my success but also with
my fulfillment I wasn't always like this
I was more on the side of being
achievement oriented driven hardwork and
concrete grinding out grinding out day
after day and I found myself really
depressed even though I was having all
of these success in my life I never took
a moment to really appreciate them and
as a result I became really upset with
who I became which is what made me learn
the lesson
gratitude you have to take a moment and
really be grateful for all the things
that are coming your way as much as I
want to be a better coach I'm already
better than I was a year ago being
grateful for that gives me the
fulfillment to go ahead and do amazing
things with my life and that is why
having a Champions mindset is about
having the balance between the two both
not being complacent and being grateful
all at the same time the question of the
day is what is that one big goal you
have and what is that one thing that
you're really grateful for please write
in the comments below and I'll join in
on the discussion I have a special shout
out from Martin Galvan jr. thank you so
much for picking up a copy of evans book
your one word and I really hope you're
enjoying the read so thank you so much
for watching we believe in you and I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is and we'll
see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of espresso
[Music]
the champions mindset I think a lot of
people hear the word champion they think
of a famous sports star you might think
of in the US you might think of a
Michael Jordan or LeBron James going and
dunking on somebody but we think of it
differently and we think of it as well
when you get on the field put everything
you have into it put every ounce of
energy you have on the field leave
nothing on the field and to when you get
knocked down because if you're an
entrepreneur you inevitably you will be
when you see hard times and you get
knocked down get back up and if you keep
putting everything you got into it and
you keep getting back up when you get
knocked down it's almost impossible to
fail something you said that you you're
reaching your peak do you think though
you can still take it to another level
or do you think this is as good as it's
going to get for you well I like to use
one quote that the limitations exist
only in our minds and if you start using
imaginations then your your
possibilities become limitless so that's
that's kind of a mindset that I have I
use my imagination I I do see myself
achieving more I'm hoping I'm working
hard on it not only myself but the
entire team around me and the core
business development system in any
company and every company sitting here
no matter what kind of company it is is
lead generation lead conversion client
fulfillment how many people do you
attract to your door how do you convert
a larger and larger percentage of those
people to become customers and how do
you convert the largest percentage of
those customers to become clients and
the ballgame of that is mindset it's
truly the paradigm through which you
approach the building of the systems
through lit which leadership and
entrepreneurship becomes a reality every
single day in the company